lors d'une course des jeux olympiques de
624 avant jésus-christ h il laisse à son
adversaire une tortue prendre 900 mètres
d'avancé
il paraît évident concours en dix fois
plus vite que la tortue h ils finiraient
par la dépasser et pourtant le
philosophe grec zénon sembla avoir
trouvé la preuve qu'à chine ne pourra
jamais dépasser la torture comme le
faisait remarquer et non pour dépasser
la tortue h il doit revenir à hauteur de
la tortue mais pendant ce temps la
tortue aura avancé du coup maintenant h
il doit atteindre la nouvelle position
de la tortue mais encore une fois
pendant ce temps la tortue aura à
nouveau avancer et ainsi de suite
et encore et encore et encore et encore
et encore et encore ce qui conduit à la
stupéfiante conclusion suivante
peu importe le nombre de fois cash il
rattrape une position de la tortue à
chine ne pourra pas dépasser la torture
bizarre je vous laisse y réfléchir et
pendant ce temps je vais réagir au titre
de cette vidéo vous avez peut-être déjà
vu cette fameuse preuve on écrit x est
égal à 0,9 9,9 9 à l'infini alors 10 x x
est égal à 9,9 9-9-9 l'infini mais du
coup quand on calcule 10x - x les
décimales s'annulent tout on obtient
l'égalité 10x - xc gagnent 9 12 noeuds
fixé gagnent 9 et du coup x égal 1
autrement dit on à l'incroyable égalité
0999 est égal à 1
est ce que c'est vraiment vrai est ce
que la preuve que je viens vous donner
est vraiment juste vient pour comprendre
cet étrange égalité revenons-en à
achille et la tortue
quand ashley latin la position initiale
de la tortue il aura parcouru 900 mètres
comme la tortue va dix fois moins vite
elle aura parcouru 90 mètres pendant ce
temps pendant cacher le court ces 90
mètres additionnels
la tortue l avance de 9 mètres et ainsi
de suite
mettons tout ça en kilomètres maintenant
vous me voyez venir la distance cacher
le parcours se décompose en une seule
0,9 km + 0 9 km + 0 009 km et ainsi de
suite jusqu'à l'infini et ça ça nous
donne exactement zéro vers de 9 9 9 9
répétées de kilomètres et ça quand on y
réfléchit c'est assez surprenant onu
nous sommes infinie de termes tout
strictement positif mais cette somme
infinie est finie et c'est là que réside
la faille dans le raisonnement de zénon
en effet h il sera une infinité de fois
derrière la tortue mais ça ne
l'empêchera pas de dépasser la torture
en un temps fini car il y à un nombre
infini d'instants dans un intervalle
fini de temps d'un point de vue
mathématique tout ce que je suis en
train de dire c'est qu'un intervalle de
l'ensemble des reals un segment de la
droite des réels même s'il est finie il
contient un nombre infini de points est
d'ailleurs le moment où h il valait
vraiment dépassé la tortue ça va être le
moment où le raisonnement de zénon ne va
plus marcher
c'est intéressant voilà pourquoi on peut
calculer la distance cash il aura
parcouru au moment de dépasser la tortue
d'une toute autre manière
en effet rappelons cacher le court ici
dix fois plus vite que la tortue du coup
quand h il aura parcouru 1000 m la
torture n'aura parcouru 100 mais comme
la tortue avait 900 mètres d'avancé
à cet instant précis
achille dépassera la tortue h il dépasse
donc la tortue au bout d'un kilomètre
mais on allait plutôt qu'à distance cash
il a parcouru en restant derrière la
tortue était 0999 à l'infini de
kilomètres du coup encore une fois on
est tenté de conclure que 0999 est égal
à 1
mais pour aller plus loin il nous faut
vraiment comprendre ce qu on entend
vraiment par 09 et bien une façon de
définir ce nombre s'est de l'écrire
comme la somme infinie de 0,9 plus 0,09
plus 0,009 et ainsi de suite à l'infini
on obtient là une somme infinie et on a
déjà vu un exemple de somme infini dans
le tout premier épisode de ce forum
lorsque je vous avais dit que pi et est
égal à 4 ou moins qu'un tiers +4/5 dont
4/7 et ainsi de suite à l'infini mais
qu'est ce que cette égalité que je viens
d'écrire veut vraiment dire si la somme
est infinie il m'a ensuite ivement ce
que ça veut dire c'est que plus on
rajoute de termes plus on se rapproche
de pi je veux pas rentrer ici dans la
formalisation de ce que je viens de dire
je vous conseille les vidéos de wanted
pour aller en savoir plus mais sachez
que si on peut montrer que plus on
rajoute de terme dans cette somme plus
on se rapproche de 1
si on arrive à montrer ça eh bien on
aura tout simplement prouvé par
définition qu'elles sont infinies que
0,9 est exactement égal à monteront donc
cachent ils se rapprochent infiniment
près de 1 km au fur et à mesure qu'ils
se rapprochent de la tortue et bien au
moment où il a atteint la première
position de la tortue h ils se
retrouvent à 0,1 km du 1 km la seconde
fois il n'est plus qu'à 0,01 km puis
0,001 km et ainsi de suite
on voit clairement que la distance qui
sépare achille d un kilomètre se réduit
à néant
au fur et à mesure cache il se rapproche
de la tortue
et ça ça prouve bien que 0,9 +0 09 p
0,009 et ainsi de suite jusqu'à l'infini
est exactement égal à 1
en fait ce que je viens de déclarer ici
revient à un calcul et la soustraction 1
- 0 9 9 à l'infini vous propose de poser
l'opération pour faire cette
soustraction remarque d'abord que 1 est
égal à 1,0000 un infini alors d'habitude
quand on fait une soustraction on est
censé commencer à droite mais on peut en
fait commencer par la gauche aussi
en fait quand même et le faire remarquer
mon professeur de maths préféré beaucoup
de matheux préfère commencer à l'ordre
soustraction à gauche même si c'est pas
du tout ce qu'on aura appris ce que je
trouve assez amusant mais bref pour
faire une soustraction en commençant de
la gauche il faut anticiper la retenue
qui va venir de la droite
en effet à droite on va devoir faire 0 -
il va donc y avoir une retenue va donc
anticiper la retenue qui nous vient du
zéro ce qui va nous conduire à calculer
un chiffre d unités égal à un monde ce
qui fait zéro peut mettre la virgule
maintenant puis on doit calculer 10 - 9
sauf qu'encore une fois il faut
anticiper la retenue qui vient de la
droite
si bien qu'il nous faut en fait faire 10
- 9 + 1 c'est-à-dire 10.10 ce qui fait
un nouveau zéro mais on tombe à nouveau
sur le même problème quand on passe à
deux chiffres après la virgule n'a 10.9
avec la retenue qui me fait faire 10 -
10 on obtient alors 0 et ainsi de suite
au fur et à mesure qu'on se déplace vers
la droite si bien que l'on a en fait ici
prouver que 1 - 0,9 9,9 9,9 à l'infini
est égal à 0,00 0,00 0,00 à l'infini
autrement dit
1 est égal à 0,9 9,9 et tout ceci nous
mène à la question la plus intéressante
finalement de cette vidéo
pourquoi est-ce que écrire 0 9 9 9 9 à
l'infini égale 1-1 nous perturbe
je sais qu'après fois que j'ai vu ça
j'ai pas cru pourquoi est-ce que de
prime abord on est si mal à l'aise à
l'idée d'écrire cette égalité bien il me
semble que le problème c'est que l'on a
l'habitude de penser que deux choses
écrites différemment représente deux
choses différentes et c'est finalement
quelque chose d'assez remarquable que
cela soit voie pour une ombre natural
les nombreux naturelles ont une écriture
unique au 01 gauche prêt et ce fut
vraiment une révolution des
mathématiques quand on s'est rendu
compte que l'on pouvait décrire les
nombres avec une écriture unique
après tout il ya pas si longtemps les
plus grands savants de notre planète
utiliser des croix à dvd bâton pour
présenter les nombres oui c'est abriter
louis et crois mes bâtons
et on avait des écritures différentes
pour des nombres similaires comme par
exemple 4 pouvait s'écrire bâton de
bâton bâton bâton ou bâton ou v et bien
ce qu'on a réussi à faire depuis en
utilisant les chiffres arabes avec les
nombres naturel c'est à dire avoir une
représentation unique de chaque nombres
entiers naturels
malheureusement on n'a pas réussi à le
faire pour les nombres réels et en
particulier il y à des nombres réels qui
ont des écritures différentes
en fait il ya un nombre infini de
nombreux réels qui ont plusieurs
écriture et je vous laisse d'ailleurs
les caractériser ça a quelque chose à
voir avec les nombres rationnelle dont
les dominateurs sont divisés
publiquement pardonné par cinq
jeudi c'est ce que j'aime retenir de
tout ça c'est que même dans le monde-
rigoureuse posément bien défini et sans
ambiguïté des mathématiques
il ya finalement des trucs qui nous
perturbent juste par la manière dont on
représente les objets mathématiques même
en mathématiques la simple utilisation
de certains symboles ou certaines
notations peuvent nous induire
directement en erreur est ce que vous
pouvez imaginer ce que ça donne dans le
monde réel dans le monde où nous disent
des mots de la langue française qui sont
ultra connoté qui ont plein de sens
différent combien d'erreurs
d'interprétation ou de raisonnement sans
nous amener à faire lorsque l'on
raisonne dans le monde si ambiguë du
langage français est la leur en a parlé
des grands nombres et prend cote
augustin nous fait parler de la théorie
de ramsey et fait remarquer que dans un
univers suffire mon grand bain ils
devraient avoir du coup forcément plein
de combinaisons qui font qu'en fait la
vie devrait forcément exister du coup la
vie du poids qu'une conséquence du fait
que les nuées a suffisamment grand pour
que forcément il est de la vie ça
c'était un raisonnement qui avait pas
mal explorées notamment un certain doute
paul sman à la fin du 19 siècle oui se
posait justement la question de si
l'univers est infini du coup il ya
forcément la vie à gauche à droite
parfois faut vraiment aller chercher des
googleplex devait être avant de trouver
la vie mais elle devrait être à gauche
et de droite
cependant pour bolt soigné rester un
truc extrêmement étrange c'est le fait
que notre vie quotidienne à une entropie
est extrêmement faible
alors que pour qu'il y ait de la vie a
priori il n'y a pas besoin d'avoir une
entreprise aussi faible qu'il se passe
quelque chose de bizarre spaceman vous
invite à en savoir plus sur l'entropie
avec cette superbe vidéo de patience
antoine de la guesse à doha ce sont des
signes que je n'ai pas parlé de tri de 3
et j'ai une très bonne raison pour ne
pas avoir parlé de tri de droit c'est
que je ne connaissais pas mais du coup
depuis jerry secondaire j'ai appris et
c'est un truc assez marrant donc la
première étape pour voir construire
trier de 3 c'est d'abord considérer un
ensemble de liste fini de symboles avec
des parenthèses ouvrant et fermant
crochet ouvrant et fermant et accolades
ouvrant et fermant et on va s'autoriser
uniquement des listes de ces symboles
qui sont légales c'est-à-dire on n'a pas
droit de fermer une porte est ouverte
et puis on a le droit de fermer une
parenthèse ou une accolade - crochet
uniquement si l'expression qui est à
l'intérieur de ces parenthèses crochet
ou accolades et elle-même l'éditeur même
une expression légale de votre langage
cela correspond à un truc très très
naturelles qui ont fait toujours
normalement avec des parenthèses a
décroché et des accolades la question
qui va se poser c'est maintenant si j'ai
deux listes de ses symboles
est-ce que je peux passer de l'un à
l'autre du plus grand au plus petit avec
trois règles la première règle c'est que
si on a décroché à des guillemets ou des
parenthèses qui n'ont rien à l'intérieur
on peut les enlever et dm règle c'est
que si elles contiennent une expression
qui est déjà entre crochets entre
parenthèses ou entre accolade
alors je peux enlever les parenthèses de
crochets accolade tableau tours et la
dernière règle c'est que j'ai le droit
de transformer des accolades ans
décrochait ou en des parenthèses et j'ai
le droit de transformer des crochets en
des bordaises et c'est tout les trois
règles et ensuite la question que
s'était posée crucial dans les années 60
c'était de savoir si on pouvait faire
une liste de liste ou le énième éléments
de la liste de liste contient au plus
deux n symbole avec la propriété qu'on
ne pouvait jamais réduire un élément en
bas de la liste
un élément qui est plus haut dans la
liste et kruska l'a démontré qu'on ne
pouvait pas construire de telles listes
qui soit 1 finit bien tri de 3 c'est la
longueur de la plus longue liste que je
peux construire tels qu' aucun élément
de la liste ne peut se réduire à un
élément précédent à travers les trois
règles que j'ai énoncé précédemment
et ce qui est vraiment surprenant c'est
que la longueur de cette liste est un
nombre incroyablement bien plus grand
que le nombre de gran d une ou deux
grammes est déjà très bon
c'est ultra contre-intuitif ans je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens que ça
surprend beaucoup de mathématiciens qui
sont surpris par le fait que tri de 3
est aussi grande que moi je
j'arrive pas à le croire ça me dépasse
largement le plus surprenant est temps
que si on ne s'autorise que deux
symboles si on n'a pas le droit
d'utiliser l'accolade est bien la plus
longue liste que l'on peut faire une
liste de trois mille maux qui la liste
qui hélas aucun des éléments de la liste
de peut être élu est un élément au
dessus mais dès qu'on passe à trois
symboles on a un truc énorme et on peut
généraliser sa est passé à cassen bol où
on peut rajouter par des guillemets ou
des légumes mais avec différentes
couleurs ou des guillemets avec
différents numéros
puis on peut en prendre autant
conversion à reprendre qu'à la plus
longue liste que je peux construire
comme ça va être tri le ksc mais non ils
sont incroyablement beaucoup plus grand
que le nombre de grammes
mais tant qu'à parler des très grandes
en moins eh ben j'ai envie de vous
parler du coût du busy bieber ou du
castor à ferrer en français qui est une
suite de nombres
un peu comme la fonction de tri de cas
en une suite visible yvr deux cas la
construction du bees beaver à avoir avec
les calculs les plus longs que l'on peut
faire avec des algorithmes et de taille
finie parce qu'on prend une taille de
fini d'algorithmes parole de faire plus
de dix lignes de codes par exemple
plutôt à plus de 100 symbole quoi sur le
langage c'est si vous voulez le visible
vers qui va correspondre à ça va être le
programme le plus long que vous pouvez
construire qui va finir par terminé par
marché alors la longueur ici en fait on
la mesure pas en temps mais en taille
mémoire que ça prend un instant donné du
calcul et quand on fait grossir cas là
on obtient des noms qui sont vraiment
vraiment vraiment énorme en fait on peut
prouver sa série 3 passes et uche qui
est la fonction busy bieber de cas croît
plus vite vers l'infini que n'importe
quelle fonction calculable en
particulier la fonction trio cas parce
qu'à force contre
ll reste calculable donc c'est encore
petit par rapport aux eyzies bieber elle
espère que vous avez aimé cette vidéo la
première fois on va parler de piles de
cartes
imaginez que vous avez une pile de
cartes et qu'on l'invité au bord d'une
tape
est ce que vous pouvez faire pencher
cette île de cartons poussant aussi loin
que de la table que vous le voulez je
vous laisse réfléchir à ça si vous avez
aimé cet îlot penser à la ligue et à la
commenter à la partager
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas
manquer les futurs épisodes et j'espère
que je verrai la prochaine fois pendant
qu'il continue de courir jusqu'à elle
elle aura encore avancé et ainsi de
suite à l'infini il ne pourra donc
jamais le dépasser